c'est pas du luxe ce sont des cellules
de 9 m² et surtout c'est de la
protection mais ça ce qu'on dit que
c'est le quartier des personnes
vulnérables et oui c'est ça ces vip à
vulnérable vulnérables ça veut dire que
si ces gens là n'ont pas de cellules
séparées ils peuvent être menacés
frappés rackettés vous imaginez un
ancien ministre de l'intérieur dans une
cellule avec tout le monde c'est pas
possible donc il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que de faire ça et encore une
fois c'est pas des privilèges du luxe et
de la précaution alors rêvons pas du
tout d'accord comme les autres détenues
pourquoi un autre détenu serait pas
vulnérable tu sais qui c'est qui
rentrent en présent il ya des gens qui
rentrent en prison qui sont vulnérables
qui se font taper par d'autres gens en
prison qui se font racketter et pourtant
les mets pas dans des quartiers vip site
ministre de l'intérieur comme tad il
fallait pas faire de conneries pour
aller en prison ça tu avais une belle
vie comme jean luc lahaye
ici
je suis
des justice à deux vitesses où on dit
parce que tu es fric et parce que tu es
connu parce que tes ministres va aller
là-bas
se parler c'est pas l'intérêt chocolat
chaud et du couscous et toi t'es vu le
pt fait enlever ton permis parce que tu
as perdu des points ou autres une
histoire de cannabis tu peux être aussi
vulnérable est certes ap tu l'aimés avec
tout le monde faut pas aller en prison
ça l'homme aux cinq ans qu'est ce que
vous répondez à un mec gentil oeil dans
leur maison à l'atome ont raison d'abord
tu ne viennes limite ça n'existe pas du
vip en prison ça n'existe pas il ya qu'à
la santé qui a eu le mot vip
tout le monde peut aller seul en cellule
tout le monde tout le monde tout le
monde la seule différence était
invulnérable donc tu as peur de tout le
monde donc il suffit que tu mens en
prison tu dis tu t'es fait frapper
d'accord on te met tout seul il ya des
quartiers tout seul ensuite est ce que
vous avez fait vous marquants non je ne
veux pas les matons je me suis fait
frapper non alors le problème
va permettre à pédaler ou pas toi tu me
laisses pas finir je peux même pas tu as
tu veux faire les pièces jouées réponse
en même temps vas-y alors il ya une
chose que je vais te dire les médiatiser
ils sont obligés d'être seul mac en quoi
ses passions en vérité ce qui s'appelle
pas du vip c'est la chose la plus
horrible au monde d'être seul d'accord
t'es en promenade dans un toit ce matin
des grillages était seul avec deux
bâtons tu peux pas rigoler avec personne
tu sors de pro natura dans ta cellule
était surveillé à l'oeil 24 sur 24 à en
prison les mecs qui sont comme ci aux
victimes en vérité sont pas bien dit pas
droit au téléphone parce que ta cellule
et filles étaient allés fouiller tout le
temps qu en réalité en prison tu peux
avoir un téléphone tu peux manger des
choses qu'on n'ira pas en prison un
scoop c'est vraiment sûr que balkany
guéant et compagnie la la la clé qui
n'ont pas de téléphone ils ont pas de
télé
attaché comme ça il a caché sur place ou
peixoto armonk a été en prison non j
moi je parle de la réalité est là tu as
les paroles s'envolent les écrits
restent j'étais en prison j'ai été 10
g/t au vip la santé c'est du vip la
santé a à mon époque c'est quoi alors
c'est quoi alors viiip c'est un des
surveillants s'écrie sourire donc
accueilli ces suis là depuis dix matches
et le vip les mots vieilles peurs ya
deux télés moi aussi mais là c'est une
télé c'est le que de décodeurs de tv
alors mais là c'est la carte des piles
laxiste s'il vous plaît ouais donc
l'avantagé qui a uni et puis à la santé
bon l'avantagé quand tu es connu c'est
tout le monde est bien avec toi en
réalité tout le monde veut être bien
avec toi donc capuche davantage que les
autres tu dis je une douche à l'époque
ça je t'ai pas les douches tu veux une
douche honte mais quand tu vas à deux
touches de balle en promenade honte mais
quand tu veux mais les quartiers de vip
n'existe pas en prison ça s'appelle de
l' isolement il n'y a pas de quartier
vip on peut me dire ce qui n'existe par
la santé ça existe simonis la santé et
bien ce qu'on parle il saura salle à son
nom à l'époque à l'époque mais ça
s'appelle quartier vip aujourd'hui
s'appelle pull quartier vp ça s'appelle
le quartier d'isolement papillon voilà
donc à par exemple moi qu'à peine que je
suis arrivé je me suis discuter avec eux
pour ne pas être dans ces trucs là ah
ouais je me suis battu je me suis battu
je redis ce faire tu le fais pas tu
voulais pas trop pourquoi tu veux jouer
moi je suis blanc et tout le monde quand
tu es bien avec l'éveil de la prison de
quantico maintenant tu te prend pour une
star c'est normal qu'ils ont les boules
maintenant qu a atteint paquet de
bonbons te donne pas un peu aux gens
mais qui valident leur métier qui cette
merde il va être frappé pour que le
prendre non quand ils rentrent
emprisonne-t-on cerveau du doigt est en
prison il doit pas être à l'extérieur tu
vis dans un autre monde il ya des gens
que tu as jamais côtoyé tamis que tu
sais pas comment ils sont comment mais
il ya une chose je dois faire attention
à tout le seul problème qu'on a en
prison et ça je sais pas qu'est ce qu'il
a dit vous deux excusez moi quand je dis
vous de en gras ça veut dire que le seul
problème c'est qu'on nous mélange mois
après j'ai réussi à me retirer du
dooly's allemand ils m'ont mais en
quartier bon tout seul aussi tout seul
ils m'ont mis au quartier haut des deux
à fleury le seul problème qui a c'est
que les gens tu as des gens qui vont
t'adorer horaire on est là basit a dit
mais qui vont essayer de te défendre et
puis tu as des mecs qui vont essayer de
te racketter mais tu as des mecs dedans
je vous expliquais ya même des gens qui
vont en prison pour rester en prison
pas parce qu'ils veulent sortir c'est
parce que y'en a qui font leur business
il ya des épiceries en prison il ya tous
en prison c'est comme si c'était la rue
c'est alerté dans la rue c'est à dire
c'est du business des chances quelque
chose pour quelque chose quelque chose
mais les viiip ça n'existe pas ouais je
suis à khimki qui a dû vip en prison ben
ali alors qu'on a vu c'est pas vrai je
ne te dirai site une clé chez lui ça
existe toutes les cellules alors tu me
lis le vip maintenant 100 ans et des tas
de 5,6 toujours assez brillant oui oui
donc mais ça va oui c'était comme ça
mais dans toutes les prisons c'est comme
ça
et encore même si neuf mètres carrés
voulez combien quelques arrêts maladie
non mais ce que je note qu'areva allait
révéler moi j'écoute pardon mais ni toi
ni moi n'avons été en lice avant que
j'écoute marco ce qui là lui le vécu et
quitte quand il te dit que le vieil pis
ça n'existe pas et qu'en fait il s'agit
d'y mettre des personnes vulnérables
quand on est condamnant médiatique et
sud - valérie médiatique et et voilà et
et notamment et aussi des personnes
vulnérables mais non ils sont pas
pareils non médiatique c'est vrai il a
raison médiatique c'est un quartier
privé vulnérables c'est un autre
quartier vulnérables mais il ya beaucoup
de menteur il ya beaucoup de menteur
tout le monde a envie d'être seul en
cellule tout le monde a envie de
s'amuser encore épaté avec toi non moi
j'étais obligé d'être seul non bien sûr
qu'ils en avaient envie de toi
[Rires]
pas dormir
avec ebay tichit
et à une caste hannibal
rapport au mileu sentir
vraiment envie de me sentir donc
l'histoire année le bien de vivre en
communauté mais à l'extérieur par
l'intérieur alors